good evening well we start with that
breaking news and in the last few
minutes
it has been confirmed that manchester
united's premier league game with
liverpool
has been postponed that's after fans
broke into old trafford to protest
against the club's owners
it had been due to kick off at half past
four this afternoon but now
it will not take place earlier
supporters gathered to demonstrate
outside the stadium calling for the
glazer family to step down
following the club's failed attempt to
join the controversial european super
league
several hundred fans broke down the
barriers entered the stadium and as you
can see there they ran onto the pitch
with some
even climbing the goal posts guys fraser
moored is live
outside the manchester united team hotel
in manchester and phrased that news in
the last few minutes
that the match has indeed been postponed
that's right it's news that we were
perhaps expecting and have been
expecting for the past couple of hours
we knew that it had been delayed
because of the incidents obviously at
old trafford and because of protests
that happened here at the team hotel
in manchester as well but uh finally
confirmation coming through
that the game has now been postponed
we've got a statement here from the
premier league
which says following the security breach
at old trafford the manchester united vs
liverpool game
has been postponed this is a collective
decision from the police
both clubs the premier league and local
authorities it goes on to say the
security and safety
of everyone at old trafford remains of
paramount importance
we understand and respect the strength
of feeling but condemn all acts of
violence criminal damage and trespass
especially given the associated covid19
breaches
fans have many channels by which to make
their views known it says
but the actions of a minority scene
today have no justification
we sympathize with the police and
stewards who had to deal with a
dangerous situation
that should have no place in football
the rearrangement of the fixture
will be communicated in due course and
we knew that it was going to be
a safety issue we knew that there were
potential kovid 19 breaches once fans
had managed to get
inside the old trafford stadium although
we had initially been told by
the sources at the premier league that
because they hadn't got into the
dressing rooms that there had been
no breaching of the kovit 19 bio
security bubble and that potentially
covered restrictions had still been met
and the game could potentially
have still gone ahead however the
security concerns have been
the main issue of course they can't
guarantee the safety of fans stewards
and the players or staff at old trafford
and so
the game has been postponed many of the
fans wanted
a postponement they wanted to get their
message across and that this is surely
the strongest way to get that message
across a lot of the fans they don't
agree with
what happened inside the stadium i was
talking to some supporters here at uh
outside the team hotel who were
protesting earlier and they said that
they thought that that was
going too far and that that was showing
the protest in a bad light by actually
forcing entry to the stadium getting on
the pitch and potentially
causing criminal damage in terms of any
arrests that have been made not sure
what's happened
at old trafford in terms of arrest i've
seen one arrest be made here just in the
last half hour or so there's a small
pocket of about
100 or so fans uh who uh who've been
here
throughout the afternoon there are on a
road one of the exit roads here
from the lowry hotel a big cheer from
them went up when the news came through
that the match had been postponed they
clearly thought that their message had
been heard and that they've had the
biggest impact
they could have had today in terms of
the effect on that match and the
publicity that that will garner for
their cause
which is of course to have the glazers
the american glazer family removed from
ownership
of the club something they've been
campaigning for for many years now but
which has been brought into
sharper focus with the recent uh
attempted
setting up of the european super league
the players themselves
still inside the hotel here i saw
through one of the windows earlier a
couple of the
a couple of the players looking out to
see what was happening with a minor
disturbance outside which involved
police getting right shields out but
eventually not having to use them
there were some missiles thrown but that
has now been calmed down
so the team coaches are still here
waiting to take the manchester united
players
to their next destination one would
assume that that would be uh to collect
their cars or to wherever
those vehicles have been left maybe to
the manchester united training ground
maybe to all traffic itself once things
have quietened down there but of course
the breaking news at the moment is that
the
the game that should have started at 4
30 that match between bitter rivals
manchester united and liverpool
will now not be taking place today at
all
okay fraser thank you